sixty-five million years ago the
chick-fil-a meteor hit the earth near
the yucatan peninsula
its impact kicked up so much dust the
sun was blocked for years
photosynthesis ground to a halt on the
other side of the planet perhaps
accelerated by chiksalab one of the
largest volcanic features on the planet
was forming
the indian deccan traps belching out
large amounts of climate changing gases
mass extinctions followed including that
of all the non-avian dinosaurs
which have been doing pretty well for
themselves for many tens of millions of
years
there is still disagreement about how
long it took mammals to begin to
diversify to turn into the great chaotic
mess of nearly 5 000 mammal species
extant on the planet today
half of which are rodents another
quarter of which are bats and the
remaining quarter of which include forms
as varied as dolphins and kangaroos
elephant seals and antelope rhinoceroses
and lemurs
sometime back when dinosaurs still
reigned primates emerged from the
mammalian ranks
against the odds our primate ancestors
managed to survive the mass
extinction 65 million years ago as did
the ancestors of every other organism on
the planet today
100 million years ago well before
chicksaleb the common ancestor of all
humans was a small
nocturnal tree-dwelling primate it was
cute and fuzzy
the one point here i have a footnote
that you're not sure you disagree
you agree with that it was cute and
fuzzy and lived in small family groups
you just didn't want it
it's undignified to call it cute and
fuzzy i think that our
100 million year old primate ancestor
was undignified that's what i think that
is possible
yeah it was cute and fuzzy and lived in
small family groups
as primates we developed greater agility
dexterity and sociality
we primates are still eukaryotes animals
vertebrates craniates
bony fish amniotes and mammals each
successive
less inclusive group providing greater
precision rather than putting the lie to
any earlier group membership
primates developed opposable thumbs and
big toes acquired pads on her finger and
toe tips and replaced claws with nails
everything about our hands and feet was
becoming more dexterous more suited to
fine motor activities
we early primates became excellent
climbers too by virtue of the terminal
long bones in our legs and arms becoming
less cemented to one another less stuck
in place
climbing ability came at the cost of
some stability on flat ground
which provided even more reason to hang
out in trees
as primates we became more visual and
less olfactory our noses shrunk and our
eyes grew
primates are not as good at the chemical
senses olfaction or taste as are the
other mammals
just as mammals before us got brainier
relative to their ancestors we primates
got brainier too compared to the other
mammals
at the same time gestation length
expanded but babies cooked for longer
inside mom before being born
litter size fell so mothers had fewer
children at a time to tend to
the period of parental investment after
birth lengthened and intensified
and sexual development happened later
and later giving ever more time for
young primates to learn how to feel
how to think and how to be
and there's another section about that
long that i can read or we can stop
there
um your call yeah well um
that's primates for you that's primates
for you right
and i in part i wanted to read that
section
to point out that so many of the things
that we think are so unique to humans
um are not um are not what we would call
synapomorphs of humans they're not
they're not
unique and derived to humans we
inherited them from our ancestors
and it's certainly true that humans are
unique in ways that far surpass uh the
uniqueness of really any other species
we're more unique as dick alexander your
your advisor and and one of my mentors
uh wrote in his extraordinary monograph
from 1990 1991 um the uniquely unique
species
and that sounds like a redundancy but
it's intentionally so
it's utterly true um and yet the fact of
us
having you know having these neo i don't
know if it's near cortexes or
neocortexes along with indexes and
indices
i'm going neocortices yeah we have these
neocortexes
um that are doing jobs have been
borrowed like
in ancient times the um
the what's now you know
what is now curled up and this massive
brain here
a lot of it was entirely about smell
and so the fact that smells can trigger
memories for instance
um is not just an accent it's not just
you know a
delightful error in fact it's just a
repurposing
of structures that uh especially for
primates
as we became more and more visual so you
know mammals became these great smellers
birds don't smell very well as birds are
incredibly visual with some exceptions
um birds like vultures yes true true um
and similarly mammals are the great
smellers of the of the vertebrate world
with some exceptions notably
primates and probably the aquatic ones
as well
well fish are the great stinkers at
least on land you know they're not
mammals right
yes no and i'm just you're talking about
fish scenzelato
mammals are the great smellers fish are
the great stinkers
that's not helpful no no no it's really
not sorry so
um i mean we so
essentially some of what we imagine is
unique to us being so
visually acute is really about what our
prime what our primary ancestors were
doing and then there's a lot more the
closer you get to us in time
um the more you see you know this
reduction in litter size and this
extending of childhood and then we get
you know a a
move away from seasonal births to having
you know having babies and therefore
being reproductively
available and interested all times of
year all of these things
are not unique to humans but they are in
our relatively recent past and they all
inform what it is that we're doing today
so i would just add
that we had a discussion i can't
remember maybe it was in a q a from a
a recent live stream in which we talked
about what creatures had the potential
to you know if we disappeared what
creatures might have the potential to do
something like what we had done and one
of the things that that conversation
settled on
was that it isn't just being a very
intelligent social creature
but it's also having the body plan
that facilitates the manipulation of the
world the testing of hypotheses etc and
so something like
a toothed whale a dolphin or an orca
which is a dolphin
would be handicapped in some sense in
reproducing our gains because
having flippers instead of hands it's
not in a good position to construct
things from experiments to buildings to
anything
and the point is okay how marvelous the
opposable thumb
right which we uh all you know
understand to be somehow important is
really initially about
gripping branches right and the point is
that's a
practical maneuvering around the world
condition but that
ends up being a precondition for the
manipulation of objects
and anyway yeah you know i'm actually
i'm not totally sure of that
um because i mean it's very hard to
figure out
the ordering of the character evolution
but um the opposable thumbs
and the loss of claws and replacement by
nails
um are kind of right next to each other
in in
evolutionary space in our history and it
feels like if it was really if it was
about gripping branches specifically
like a we can you know we can pronate
yeah um and and supinate um but if it
was mostly about gripping then the
clause it seems like would be
helpful and instead we see a loss of
clause around
something like the same time and it's
possible that someone has better um
better granularity on the timing of that
character evolution relative to the
other but i i don't at the moment
yeah well i'm now out of my depth i've
always uh imagined that
nails are somehow a better um
backing for the sensory capacity of the
fingers
right but that's that's about
manipulation of stuff right but
so i guess nothing you know i could be
dead wrong about
uh the gripping of branches and the role
that it plays i doubt it
um but even if the gripping of branches
very quickly leads
to oh well now you've got a structure
that is capable of manipulation
and so even in very primitive primates
you still have an advantage in being
able to manipulate and sense
up here which you know so even if nails
are um quickly on the heels it doesn't
mean that it is not
the precursor to the manipulative
capacity that is so
key to what we accomplished uh as humans
i'm just saying it just requires uh you
have implicit in what you're saying a
hypothesis about character order
about the order of character evolution
and i don't know that we know that to be
the case
all right well it'll be interesting to
find out yeah i guess it is a hypothesis
that makes a prediction
and and right and you were you were you
were introducing it as an assumption
rather than a hypothesis and i and i'm
i'm not sure that's borne out by the
evidence all right well we're gonna find
out because it's gonna come no i don't i
don't think we are it's my point
in part i don't i because this is such
deep history
and um you know claws and nails
don't fossilize and i don't think like
the attachment it's
it's all going to be soft tissue i just
i'm not sure there's going to be any
evidence
really um but well
yeah well we'll see if there's evidence
it will show up
it will contact us probably over email
that's not actually how it works but
okay
i will go looking and i suspect that
they won't that i won't find anything
okay um what else what else do you want
to talk about
uh well geez i feel like we've done
uh an awful lot we've gotten to mammals
whether you see them as cute and fuzzy
or
um i think now most of them are i think
that first one though
not elephant seals not elephant seals
not manatees frankly you know some
people think so
but you know whenever people say yeah
manatees is probably the origin story
for mermaids i'm like
you gotta be at sea alone yeah or be
really near sighted something
something yeah yeah i agree i agree
um yeah there i mean there are there are
a few not so not so cute mammals
you got that centurio cynics that's a
flap of skin that he uses to cover his
face so he doesn't want to
demonstrate that properly you have to
hang upside down and pull the flap
you've got to put some hooks in the
ceiling man all right fair enough
yeah what other mammals are really hard
to look at um
some people sadly yeah sadly
[Music]
you